[Music]
so here we go
now this was a king's indian and
as far as i know uh fabi
i don't know if he's ever played i mean
i'm pretty sure he has played the king's
indian before but he's not
really a king's indian player and i
think the reason
that fabi chose to play the king's
indian is because he sensed that vojtech
is not in very good form thank you mr
pereira
voit is not in very good form uh
he had lost several games in this
tournament and i think fabi just
sensed that he needs to play for a win
with the black pieces in an opening like
the queen's gamba declined
or a ragazin is just not going to cut it
mavoicek is a super solid player
and i think fabio reasoned that he's
just not going to have realistic chances
to win unless he plays something
very unbalanced and apparently was the
only second time he played the king's
indian which is amazing
to play it on such a stage against such
a player that takes some guts
okay so it's a main line king's indian
until
fabby plays a very unusual move in this
position now this is like
the main line of main lines and in this
position
uh the move knight c6 as many of you
guys i'm sure know
is the most popular move that is what's
considered the main line or the marble
plata variation
uh this leads to the very famous kind of
kings indian positions or white attacks
on the queen side and black attacks on
the king side
this by the way is called the bayonet
attack the move b4
that's like the hottest of the hut now
in my career i haven't played knight c6
very much i've played a variety of
sidelines in these positions there are
three main sidelines
you can get the knight to a6 which may
look weird until
you realize that after white plays d5
which he shouldn't by the way
because that would justify the placement
of the knight on a6 where would the
knight go this is a very typical
king's indian idea this knight goes to
what square
this knight goes to c5 in order to exert
pressure on the e4 pawn
and then we play the move a5 in order to
prevent white from playing b4
so that's another sideline black can
play e takes d4 this leads to a very
interesting kind of structure that i'm
sure you've seen
me play many times in blitz and finally
the move knight b to d7 is called
uh sort of the old main line the knight
beat d7 is what people used to play
almost exclusively
until knight c6 came around but fabi
plays
yet another move which according to my
reference here has only been played it
is
a very unpopular move it's been played
in number of popular in terms of
popularity it's knight c6 followed by
e-takes d4 followed by knight bd7
followed by knight a6 followed by c6
followed by knight h5 followed by queen
e8 followed by a5 and only then
with 119 games the move bishop g4 now it
has
been featured in uh quite a quite a few
grand master games so
although it's not very common what i'm
seeing
here and you guys can see part of the
reference here is that
a lot of grandmasters have actually
played the move bishop g4 which tells me
that it's probably not that easy for
white to prove an advantage
yeah i'm sure that fabi practice now the
idea of this move
is quite transparent i don't think fabi
is hiding
uh what he wants to do here what he
wants to do and what he does do on the
next move is to take the knight on f3
and soften up white's control over the
center now if you think about it this
bishop on g7
its ultimate aim is to exert pressure
down this long diagonal
by taking the knight on f3 uh radoslav's
control over his own d4 pawn would
uh in theory be weakened i think that's
like the general notion behind this move
right
one sec thank you squandy for the tier
one
okay so voiceshit goes bishop e3
he does that in order to remedy uh
that situation in order to give the pawn
on d4 another defender
300 bits from quarter steps now there is
uh and now the main line in this
position the most popular move is to
play d5 and simply to close down the
center
and closing down the center to me makes
a lot of sense here
because the whole point of bishop g4 is
to
soften up white's control over the
center so by closing it white could
render this move
a little bit awkward and using reference
here
the move a5 is sometimes played i'm sure
that fabi
probably had some sort of preparation
here i don't know if it involved taking
the knight on f3 which by the way is
very unusual
in the king's indian um but i'm sure
that fabi
anticipated d5 and would have done
something interesting here i see that
there is a serbian grandmaster
i think serbian euros cobaren who plays
the move knight h5
a lot so maybe it was this move that
fabi had prepared
um and in any case raduslov goes bishop
e3 fabby takes on f3
and now fabi takes the pawn on d4 which
reaches
this very interesting structure now
what's very unusual is not the structure
itself
this structure itself is not unusual in
the king's indian as i've told you guys
now if we go back to the mainline
position e takes d4 is very common
i've played this move many times myself
and it reaches
exactly this kind of pawn structure
where it's sort of like a marotzi bind
where you have a c pawn rather than an e
pawn if you think about it that way
if it helps but what's unusual about
this is
that black is actually traded uh the
light squared bishop for whites after
ignite that doesn't happen very commonly
in the king's indian
now who does this favor it's very hard
to say
because on the one hand that knight on
f3 was
seriously protecting white's central
control but on the other hand two
bishops are two bishops
and with the position being kind of open
in theory the two bishops should favor
white so my guess here is that perhaps
white has a very small edge
objectively speaking but it seems to me
quite clear that fabian prepared
this type of position at home and so he
plays knight c6 getting his night out
uh radoslaven please feel free to ask me
questions as i go along radislav
drops his bishop 23 now of course uh
white does not want to give away his
dark square bishop here that would be
positionally horrible it would give this
bishop an uncontested long diagonal
and uh fabby plays another extremely
logical move rookie eight so far he's
not doing anything extraordinary he's
bringing the rook into the game
and he's applying a little bit of
pressure on the c4 pawn
radoslav's response is similarly quite
mundane
and according to my um
reference here this position had
occurred twice before
one of the games was a quite a was a
strong
game y was 2339 and black was 2567 and
in that game
uh the move chosen by white was queen c2
but uh here radoslav goes queen to d2
would i have considered bishop takes c3
well oh
i'll get to that moment in a moment in a
second so
queen to c2 i kind of like because it
does over protect the c4 pawn
but queen d2 also looks like a perfectly
fine move you build up a little battery
you connect the rook so so far nothing
to write home about and now knight d7
yeah um no spoilers please now knight t7
now what is the purpose of this move who
can explain to me who can at least
attempt
to explain to me why move the knight
back from
f6 there's a couple of things that this
move accomplishes at least in my eye
and it's the next move that's really
shocking from from fabi
yeah so essentially this knight can
maneuver itself to one of two squares
either well first of all it opens the
bishop
it opens up the bishop now i don't think
that you're preparing f5 right because
f5 is a move is that you only really
play when the position is closed
when the position is open like this the
move f5 does more harm than good if you
think about it
then after e takes f5 g takes f5 this
pawn becomes super weak
and white can actually pick it off by
playing quay to d5 check
um so it's more that this move opens up
the bishop and allows it to really
occupy that diagonal
and the knight can be rerouted either to
e5 potentially or to c5 both of which
uh have their purpose right the knight
on e5
would would attack the bishop
potentially and attack c4 whereas on c5
it would exert pressure
uh on the e4 pawn without blocking in
that f6 uh that
dark square bishop so radislav brings
his rook
into the game rook 8 to d1 and here
comes the shocking move
and seeing this move played is quite a
shock even to me
uh and as dr dr man revealed to us
the move that fabi played here which i
think
will stun the world for months to come
is bishop higgs cp
takes the knight with his bishop one
second i need a chip
and salsa after this move as i let it
sink in for everybody
why did he take off debris
all right
so there's a lot that appears to be very
wrong with this move
this looks like a horrible move this is
the kind of move that if you saw this
played by a beginner
you would kind of smile and you would
say ah you know a young one you really
don't understand these positions do you
i mean if you just look visually to give
up such a bishop is exceedingly rare in
the king's indian
um largely because well first of all
the bishop itself is a very strong piece
it's fianchettoed on the long diagonal
and also by giving it up black is
creating
massive weaknesses on the king side
which it
may appear to the untrained eye white
can exploit by going bishop h6
and that would immediately create a
maprid on g7 the bishop serves as the
protector of the king it serves as
what seems to be black's strongest piece
and fabi takes it and gives it away
for a knight on c3 that isn't
particularly doing anything at all
and um you know i mean
this is quite shocking to me but i think
i've thought about this move
beforehand and um i have a couple of
ways i think that i may attempt to
explain why it's played
i'm quite sure that this move was
preparation he accidentally took the
night by mouse lip exactly
so first of all
first of all the concept of getting two
knights against
two bishops is not a new concept
and moves like bishop takes c3 do
occur in other types of openings like
for example
uh there is a there's a line in the
english defense let me see if i can
remember there's a line in the
symmetrical english defense
where white plays d4 take stakes black
plays g6
knight c3 bishop g bishop g7
knight c2 and in this position uh this
used to be a very popular line but along
came
people like bobby fischer and they
started taking on c3
which at first sight looks oh crazy how
can you give up such a bishop you create
a hole on g7 and in bug house this would
be unthinkable
but it turns out that the weaknesses in
white's uh
uh a lot basically justify this entire
approach and it also turns out that
white
can't really exploit the weakness of
black's dark squares because the knight
quickly comes out to f6
uh and even if black castles just
because white puts the bishop on h6 that
doesn't mean anything inherently
the bishop just kind of chills there but
not in a good way it's not really doing
anything
and it turns out the whites pawns are
kind of beginning to collapse so that's
only one of many
variations where this move bishop takes
c3 does occur and
is very well known so
if we were to compare that situation to
fabi's capture
then we can kind of see one i would say
specific similarity
which is that if you look at white's
bind particularly
that e4 pawn the e4 pawn is really
weakened
as a result of this trade thank you
chase for quick okay the e4 pawn
is actually quite weak it's defended now
only by the bishop
and it's never a good idea when a piece
is very much tied down
to the defense of a pawn and if you
think about it this knight on d7 let's
not forget where it's going
this knight is going to c5 where it's
going to actually attack this pawn on e4
and um white's bishop you know bishops
are
obviously very uh very versatile pieces
but they're not very good when they're
sort of stumbling around weak pawns
they're not necessarily the best
uh defenders of weak pawns think of the
processor
and both the c4 and e4 pawns are now
in the absence of the the knight that
kind of serves as the glue piece
kind of weak now comes the question of
how black is able to
defend against various threats like
bishop h6 and enter fabi's next move
queen f6
this move offers a queen trade and if
white accepts the queen trade amazingly
he just
loses the pawn on e4 the pawn on e4
cannot be defended
so we very clearly see the meaning of
the move bishop takes e3 here
that pawn the weakness of the pawn 94
that very concrete property
of the position justifies uh something
as
seemingly drastic as giving up the
bishop now
um basically what fabi says to white's
queen is
[ __ ] or get off the pot um if you're not
taking on f6 then white's queen has to
move away but
if white's queen moves away then ideas
like bishop h6
lose a lion's share of their
effectiveness because they no longer
threaten checkmate on g7 right
um well the problem with the move knight
to e5 would be twofold first of all
that knight on e5 is not very stable how
can white
try to chase away this knight in the
future what would white do
if we had instead played the move 95 and
please stop me if i'm not making any
sense i probably am not
this is not an easy thing to explain i
myself am not positive in the things
that i'm saying
well it's not rook d5 because if it were
black to move i would definitely take
that bishop on f3 and ruin white's king
side pawn structure
but the simplest would be to go bishop
e2 and then to play f4 but on another
more conceptual level at a more
conceptual level
think about this knight do you actually
want it to be on e5
it's blocking the rook's access to the
e4
[Music]
there we go it's blocking third time's
the charm it's uh
blocking the rook's access to the e4
pawn
and that's exactly what we want to
attack i think this is computer analysis
i mean i think that by and large
this is the product of computer analysis
but
uh the reason that the computer suggests
this move is because
it transpires that these very specific
properties of the position in particular
are the weaknesses of white central
pawns combined with
the fact that the bishop on f3 is very
passive uh
is justification enough to make a move
that
from a purely positional uh standpoint
seems to be completely unthinkable
so queen to see one by wojtershek fabi
goes knight c5
and voitusha goes queen b1 he now has to
tie down the queen
to the defense of the e4 pawn which is a
very very sad use of resources and yet
um i heard in some commentaries i think
the opinion was expressed that
voit should have just sacrificed upon an
e4 and at least gotten
activity for his pieces so one move that
comes to mind maybe something like a3
knight takes c4 b4
i don't know maybe try to get some sort
of peace activity on the queen side
and see compensation but you can imagine
how hard it is to go for something like
this
if you've never seen this idea before um
and by the way the reason bishop takes
c5 is going to be bad and this is a very
instructive moment
because this is a classic example of
um of bad bishop against good knight
look at this bishop
it's staring at the e4 pawn now look at
this knight where can this night go
does this night have an outpost
yeah it certainly does
um
and that's not just any outpost the
night is going to be completely
unassailable
completely unassailable on um
on that square okay and
we are going to permanently blockade
white's bishop we're gonna bury it
we will bury you um as russia
said with the move rookie five okay so
taking
is very very bad but if you don't take
then that pawn on e4
gets under even more fire and so queen
bee won by boitashek
fabi goes queen e6 so his play in this
part of the game makes perfect sense
guess what ladies and gentlemen this is
a fork white actually loses
a pawn here the bishops are not able to
sustain
uh a prolonged defense of these two weak
pawns and so
here we can very clearly see the sort of
concrete justification of taking on c3
this is where it's
this is the crux of why fabi took on c3
uh would bishop g5 work threatening the
rook and knight
uh in which position ryan thank you
derpy gifting two upper thighs
well b1 is not a good square for the
queen but it's the only square for the
queen
i think uh voyager could have also
defended that pawn with queen c2
but probably he didn't like the look of
what didn't he like about queen c too
let me think
hmm i mean maybe the fact that knight
before comes with tempo although i
highly doubt it
i'm not sure why boyd destroyed didn't
go queen c2 yeah because maybe he should
have gone quincy because
queen b1 i think he might have
overlooked this the the benefit of going
queen c2 over queen b1 is that queen e6
is no longer a fork
here we only attack the e4 pawn which
means that white can make a move such as
rokafi one
uh which voitushek played this move in
the game but in the game
his c4 pawn was also hanging and here he
can focus his attention
on creating an indirect defense against
the e4 pawn
thank you uh swapster for the prime so
queen bee won by way to shaquini6 and
fabi actually wins the plan b3
uh he brings the queen up to c3
vojtershek tries to get that queen out
fabi says okay
i'll bring my queen back to f6 and
already black is much better he's up
upon
the knights are pew are beautifully
placed both on protected squares
and bedazzle bedazzled fine muck and
bishop c1 by boiteshek so radislav
is once again he's trying his best
to get this bishop back onto the long
diagonal that is really his only chance
uh i in my eyes to generate some sort of
counter play
you know his only source of counterplay
is this long diagonal because black no
longer has a dark sort of bishop
um and the reason by the way that he
took on c4 instead of e4 if you think
about white's last move rook after e1
that created an x-ray against black's
queen so taking on e4 i think
would have played into white's hands and
perhaps radislav can even play bishop
takes a7 here
exposing the attack on on on the e4
night and
restoring the material balance so does
that make sense am i making sense so far
i don't know if
um you know once again please don't be
shy about clarifying things as you have
been
but here we reach uh the stage of the
game where
uh carolina i think just accumulates the
pressure on the king's side so the
knights are beautifully placed
this knight on c6 is the only well this
knight on c6 has further prospects it
can go to e5
uh at a time of black's choosing it can
also potentially go to d4 although the
d4 square is a little bit more loose
because you cannot support that knight
with the move c5 so fabi plays
h5 he improves the position of his pawns
he grabs some space on the kingside and
it's very clear to me that he prepares
uh he's preparing to attack on the king
side using his knights a bishop b2
and now he says no no no you ain't
getting
uh that long diagonal he goes 95 sticks
that knight in between the bishop
and uh and black's king
and um attacks of course the bishop on
f3 which
radoslav has to move now fabi grabs even
more space
on the king side with the move h4 and by
the way
one of the reasons behind playing h5h4
is that later in the game
fabi may have the possibility of
actually pushing the pawn even further
and this is a concept that i call
carving out you're
carving out squares near white's king on
which you can then put your pieces so if
g3 for example
what square have we carved out and what
piece could we potentially put on that
square
and i actually see kind of a nice line
here that perhaps
may faithfully illustrate
well first of all yeah g2 and f3 so we
can play knight f3 check
and if bishop takes f3 then guess what
it's a lobster pincer checkmate on g2
but if white moves the king to h1 it may
appear that black is overextended
queen is being attacked bishop is making
contact with the knight but here i think
black is a very beautiful move
black to play in wind this just gives me
a chance to
take another bite of a chip
boom goes the dynamite oh we blundered
our queen oh my god no we didn't knight
takes f2 is check mods
knight takes f2 is checkmate so
that would have been a pretty nice
conclusion to the game of course
voit has no intention of allowing any of
that and so he plays the move queen to
c1 he's like i am shutting this whole
operation down how is he preventing h3
by the way
how does the move queen c1 prevent the
move h3
alec yes it does weaken the king's side
but what fabi is basically saying is
that white doesn't have the resources
necessary to exploit this weakness
i always give the analogy of a tree
falling in the forest if nobody is
around does the tree make a sound
it's the same thing here just because
you push upon in front of your king
doesn't automatically mean that
you know that your king is going to get
checkmated because an attack depends not
only on the weaknesses but on your
opponent's capacity to exploit them
and here white just doesn't have that
capacity so the move here is f4
by putting the queen on c1 vojtech
prepares to play f4 and this would win
the knight on e5 so fabi goes g5
and he pushes another pawn in front of
his king but this time he stops the
movement four and another reason that i
think he's able to get away with this
is because he's got this queen on f6 and
the queen is really the glue piece
it's holding everything together and
also fabi has all of these pieces near
his own king
which means that he's not really afraid
of making a move like g5 to the country
white is the one who's got to be afraid
bishop b5 attacking the rook rookie 7
moving the rook
another instructive moment by the way i
think a lot of people
uh might instinctively want to play the
move c6
but why would this be inaccurate from a
conceptual standpoint why would the move
c6
be worse than moving the rook
because it weakens d6 exactly and
there's absolutely no need
to create these weaknesses when we can
just as well move the rook to e7 no
problem
rook to e3 so i think white is trying to
defend
again against the threat of h3 h3 was
now once again a very serious threat so
he defends against it
fabi repositions his queen on g6
pressures the e4 pawn
gets the queen out of the pin once and
for all and guess what this x-ray
against white's king you should already
notice it because that could become very
significant later on
bishop e2 by waiter trying to bring
bring in the beef
beef up the security around his king and
fabi
he looks around the board he identifies
the last remaining piece which is not
doing anything that is the rook
and he brings the rook into the game
look at how harmoniously all of his
pieces are playing he constantly is
improving
the placement of his pieces now i know a
lot of you are probably wondering
why knight takes c4 was not played here
and um i believe that the reason
is tactical although i'm not don't quote
me on this but perhaps white has the
move rook takes c4
and i believe that now
black does pay the price for advancing
his pawn so audaciously in front of the
king and this creates counter play
against black's king which i think
fabby just has no need to allow and so
he instead just
calmly plays the move from k to e8 queen
to c2 and now he plays another very
instructive maneuver
now there's this notion and i'm sort of
translating from the russian of a piece
having done its job
you have to be very flexible in relation
to how your pieces are placed a piece
could be doing an
amazing job on a particular square for
10-15 moves and then it's very important
to
identify when a piece has completed its
assignment on one square and when it's
needed
perhaps on another side of the board so
black has finished with white center
black is no longer interested
in winning the c4 pawn in fact this e4
pawn
is part of the reason that white's
pieces are as passive as they are now it
is time to orient black's
pieces toward a king's side attack and
looking at this knight
right now it's a vestige right it's it's
performing this
relatively unnecessary duty of
pressuring e4 and instead fabi deploys
it
to f4 knife f4 and now you can see the
storm clouds gathering around
white's king bishop f1 by voit
and now fabi plays the move c6 now
didn't i just say
that um the move c6 is bad because it
weakens d6 why is fabi doing this on his
own volition well
the circumstances have changed a little
bit and because he senses that white's
king is so weak
when the king is weak the sort of common
prescription is to open up the center
in order to allow for better
exploitation
of that king weakness so here fabi is
very specifically preparing
to rip open the center with d5 that's
all he's doing he
understands that the pawn on d6 is weak
but this is a purely temporary weakness
once he plays d5
he will no longer have that weakness
um well if if bishop takes c5 then
d takes e5 and don't don't forget that
this now becomes once again an
incredible outpost for the knight
okay yeah so i think one key
point here is that in general it is
beneficial for the two bishops
uh when the center is opened but here
you just need to compare the activity of
the pieces look at how active blacks
knights are
and look at how passive this bishop is
this bishop on b2 is active
but in and of itself it's not going to
tackle black's entire army alone
okay so fabu just basically concludes
that because his pieces are so much more
active
the time has come for him to open the
center but he does so very patiently
before playing the move d5 he makes one
more minor improvement
minor but very important improvement he
plays the move rook to e6
just making sure that you know the rook
kind of maybe defends the queen maybe
it'll later lift itself to g6
also just protecting the sixth rank
against any kind of freak ideas
fabi is in no hurry white is completely
devoid of counterplay so
vojtech goes to c3 and there goes d5
and uh here the position simply
collapses well if you had gone h3
this is no longer that effective because
white can go g3
and if the issue is we don't want to
move this knight away from f4
because if we do then white will be able
to take on h3 and
all of a sudden the tables have turned
so the knight on f4
is very well placed if it ain't broke
don't fix it d5 g3
yeah he did he played g3 anyway um and
after hghg
comes the tactical stage of the game
fabi has activated his pieces to such an
extent
that even without the f4 knight his
position is absolutely devastating he
plays d
takes e4 sacrificing that knight on f4
and i believe
that uh radaslav should have taken on e4
he should not have accepted
the knight i'm pretty sure the black is
somehow still winning
maybe the simple knight h5 knight f6
going after that e4 pawn after all would
have been a good idea for black
but at least the game goes down radislav
and time pressure plays g takes that
four he accepts
the knight after which fabi takes back
and uh queen g2 it appears actually that
that white has succeeded in trading
queens and guess what white is up a
bishop
but here fabi plays the final stage of
the game absolutely brilliantly
the absolute temptation of course is to
take on f3 with the knight
but after rook takes f3 e takes f3
queen takes f3 check queen takes g6
check if you take with a rook then white
goes king f2 and white is actually quite
fine
white's got two bis two bishops for uh
a rook and a bunch of pawns but these
pawns are tripled which means they're
probably going to be lost
but it turns out that the knight on e5
is a crucial attacker it should not be
given up at any cost
and so fabi plays e takes f3 now of
course if you play rook takes f3 then
after knight takes f3 the knight is
untouchable
due to the pin and so vojtech is forced
to capture on g6 after which fab he
takes back and here's the key
idea if white goes king f2
it may appear that white has finally
escaped black's clutches
but the killer idea and fabi had to have
seen this when he was sacrificing the
knight
silent but deadly move what might are we
thinking about here
we want to go nitro 4 but we can't we
can't because they take on f3 can we
pretend can we
uh pretend prepare what am i even saying
can we protect
that f3 pawn first before playing issue
for bingo rook g3 is correct
and white simply cannot stop the
devastating threat of knight before
checkmate
if white drops his king to e1 well that
may stave off the checkmate but it's not
going to
change the outcome of the game knight d3
check and knight takes b2 ah
look who's in the chat to offer his
input gm hess
i don't know who that person is but i
was going to say the commentary was
exceptionally terrible
i think hess should step in to actually
help out the commentary team because
they're really suffering but that is the
key
point without this move rook g3 white
would have actually recovered and so
king h1 is a sad necessity
now fabi goes f2 and prepares to drive
the rook into g1
radislav has to play bishop h3 and the
final two moves of the game
absolutely superb tactical vision by
fabi
he realizes that he wants the rook to
get to e1
and if the rook gets to e1 the game is
over but
just moving the knight anywhere gives
white
advanced notice that we want to play
rookie one so if you play knight d7 for
instance
then rook c1 would have followed and at
least white prevents
rookie one so fabi understands that he
has to put the knight on a square
where it also creates a threat uh
to one of white's pieces and so the move
is 94. now knight f3 you guys i actually
think would be a bit sloppy
because after rook takes f3 rookie one
check i don't have to take the rook i
can play bishop f1
and after rook takes d1 because you've
played knight after you have positioned
white tsuruk on the ideal square to take
on f2
so the move knight c4 is much stronger
rook takes you for rookie one check and
voiceok resigned
because after king h2 rook takes d1 rook
takes f4
who can tell me what black's most simple
liquidation is to a completely winning
position
black can simply win decisive amount of
material here with a very nice
final mini combination we need to notice
that the king and the bishop are on the
same rank which means that if we put the
rook on d2 it is essentially a fork we
can start with the move f1 queen
or we can immediately play rook d2 it
doesn't even matter rook d2 is probably
even stronger
because the threat of rook takes b2 as
well as f1 queen
even f1 knight is a threat of checkmate
and two
and so uh voyage resigned after that's
your rookie one shaq and that was an
amazing game 39 moves
and it really all started with with this
incredible idea not of capturing on f3
that's pretty normal
although you don't see that every day
but this idea of bishop takes e3 is
going to go down as i believe
a a symbol an epitome of modern chess
like if you want
a mental reference of modern chess
then that is the move bishop takes c3 a
move that 25 30 years ago even
would have been lot laughed out of the
tournament hall you know if you play a
move like this
you know you would have gotten your
hands chopped off in russia
but nowadays the importance of concrete
factors
has really become the most important
uh you know the most important
evaluative
notion in any position it's not really
about these general principles you can
give up any piece in any position
as long as there are specific factors
that justify it and in this case the
weakness of white's
central pawn bind combined with the
slight awkwardness and passivity of the
bishops
meant that in this very specific case
black's two knights
are able to overpower with the help of
you know this very important move queen
f6 are able to overpower the two bishops
and as a consequence fabi was able to
win upon i do believe that queen c2
may have afforded better defensive
chances because queen b1 maybe white
shark just missed queen e6
but once fabi won the pawn and
repositioned his queen and his knights
on ideal squares
the game was essentially decided and the
rest was a matter of bringing the pieces
in very patiently to the king side
and it culminated in a absolutely
brilliant attacking sequence where fabi
sacrifices one of his knights for the
greater good
okay um that was
tough sorry i really i talked too much
but i hope that made at least a little
bit of sense
i do think that it was prep and i'm
actually quite confident
that bishop takes c3 was prepped i think
finding this move over the board
is possible i think i wouldn't rule it
out from someone like fabi
jonathan thank you for gifting to top
mountain gaming i wouldn't rule it out
from someone like fabi but i would say
it's highly unlikely
that uh that bishop takes e3 is not
comfort over the board particularly
since i can see the time although
maybe six minutes he spent six minutes
maybe he did find it over the board
and robert brings up a great point here
it may not have been exact prep in this
position
okay it may not have been that fabi
looked at this exact position on his
computer and saw bishop takes two but
um it's it could very well be that this
idea bishop takes c3
was uh something that he noticed in a
slightly different position perhaps
within the same opening
there was a different position in which
bishop takes c3 occurred
and so he borrowed that idea from that
position and that's what might explain
the six minutes of thinking
if he started completely from scratch i
think he would have thought longer than
six minutes but as it stood
i think that's a very plausible
hypothesis wow something wise by gms
um he was trying to figure out whether
it is worthwhile
to apply that idea to this position and
the answer is yes now i would be curious
to do a position search
and see if i can find any similar
examples of somebody
earlier doing something similar let me
see
if i can kind of do that just give me a
moment
me see if i can find for you guys
a anything even resembling an idea
like this let's see if i can run a
little search
okay so just very quickly this game
between
a relatively unknown player
and um igor ivanov who unfortunately
passed away early but he was a
grandmaster who
of course russian but he moved to canada
in his later years very very strong
player
and he was facing off against the 2300
so we can see a very similar opening
very similar opening but this time c5
was played rather than e5
so there's bishop takes f3 and cd very
similar position
except um yeah basically almost
identical position in fact
with the exception that there's an e
pawn rather than a c pawn
and after knight c6 rook c8 eight five
knight d7
knight c5 in rook f21 guess what igor
ivanov played in this position
and again this is a bit of a different
situation but
i just want to show that the concept
itself uh
was around for a while bishop takes c3
so he gives up that bishop for the
knight
and his idea is very similar to that of
fabi he goes 95
and this weakness of the e4 pawn
is what makes the position very awkward
for white white cannot move the bishop
back to e2
because he loses the pawn but if he
doesn't then he risks getting his pawn
structure ruined with knight takes f3
and ultimately ivana won a very long
game he did trade on f3
ultimately he won with a is sort of a
multi-pronged assault
on white's position that the rest of the
game doesn't interest me that much
but this kind of stuff does exist yes
caruana performed a careful study of
these games
of course but in any case that's um
that's a little bit about the fabby game
i think it's good to pause there
you know so let's go back to the grind
just for a little bit
[Music]
you